a good test can anybody hear me can
everyone see how bald i am from where
you're sitting hands up if you can see
the your reflection in my head so I have
a really tough job tonight my job is to
try to keep you entertained and awake at
this time of night after you've been fed
and alcohol so I'm going to try to do
that as best I can let me introduce
myself really quickly my name is Colt
McAnlis I'm actually the team lead for
chrome developer relations performance
about a year ago in January we actually
identified that the web performance
community was good and doing well but we
didn't have someone focused on bringing
the message to people constantly as
talked about in the previous talks
tonight you know it's really easy to do
dumb slow things on the web and one of
the first things we need to do with that
is fix it with education so we kind of
define from the beginning that after
looking at all the education and looking
everything out there there's three
really three pillars of web performance
okay up until now the web as a whole has
really only focused on one of them all
you've heard for most performance
experts is how fast is your website look
right we've all seen the studies that
show that one millisecond of time
actually related to 10 million dollars
of lost revenue for site XY and Z and
they only really talk about network but
in the modern age of web applications we
often tend to neglect the other two
pillars of web performance rendering and
compute a great part of the forecast for
Castillo forecast
I wanted to see I want to see he was
listening I was good i want to i want to
see i got to keep you awake to one of
the great parts of the forecast talk i
believed was when he really said you
know we have to actually solve this
problem of rendering because it doesn't
have him for free I think the existence
of the previous type of web where CSS
animations weren't something you even
had availability to allow us to do
really stupid things and the browser
kept us really fast but now because we
kind of contend our own yard we're
running into some problems there so when
you think about performance you should
know that Network render and compute you
can have problems in all three of these
and much like Jake said earlier right
like one of a huge problem in one of
these portions can actually cloud out
issues that are happening in the other
two so as you're going through your
process of finding performance issues in
your website you need to make sure that
you're evaluating all three of these
with the right tools at the right time
and what I'm going to do tonight is I'm
going to try to walk you through some of
the sites that you've submitted hahaha
and hopefully bruise your ego a little
bit no offense it's what we all have to
do quite frankly I think one of the big
things we've been trying to do with the
web performance movement over the past
year is actually bruise a lot of egos in
the web because we're all programmers
we're all smart we're too smart quite
frankly and we got to be taken down a
peg right because we all know in here
everyone in here think think about your
coworkers right and think about what
really motivates them ninety-nine
percent of the time if you can bruise
their ego or challenge them or tell them
they're not good enough for the problems
too hard that's what actually gets them
to move right yeah okay maybe maybe
maybe you got Yankees money I guess so
so this is this is the loop right so
this is what you should all be thinking
of now I've got about ten years of game
development background under my belt I'm
a C++ programmer at heart and I'm trying
to apply a lot of the lessons we use in
game development to web development cuz
in reality we're both dealing with
real-time media interfaces right so when
you guys say how fast can something load
off an internet site I'm thinking how
fast can that stuff be streamed off a
DVD right it's the same problem we've
had just you know ten years later right
so when you're doing your performance
the main thing that you have to do is
follow these three steps the first thing
is you need to gather information right
you go open up chrome devtools you open
up pet webpagetest org this gives you
information about what is going on in
your
aged from that you actually need insight
because really what's what's a whole
sheet of floating point numbers mean to
you nothing right you need to know what
those floating point numbers mean and
your tooling system needs to be able to
infer what those floating point numbers
mean and then once you have that insight
you need to be able to actually plan in
action you have this data you have to
then go to your manager and justify
please let me spend two weeks fixing
seven milliseconds of load time from our
website because it matters then you need
to be able to repeat this constantly
constantly constantly you need
continuous integration tools need the
ability to actually track down who's
check-in broke the bill quick show of
hands how many of you in here actually
have some continuous integration for
performance in your suite right now one
two three four five well is that wait
were you just showing me your Pepsi can
okay I mean it's a cool can that's um
Bravo yeah so maybe four maybe five out
of an entire room I've asked this
question to probably about three
thousand developers this week while I've
been in New York and meeting and giving
talks and the total number of people is
close to about fifteen with the five in
this room this shows that there's a huge
problem in the web community is that
we're not actually testing for
performance and giving it the gravitas
that we are our features in our CSS and
those pretty little bubbly items
everywhere else in our pages this is why
we actually moved forward with trying to
build a better community about this so
for you in the audience this is the only
slide I want you to take away from today
burn this into your retina may you know
tweet it blog it like get a tattoo of it
if get a tattoo it tweet it to me and
I'll send you some swag please don't get
a tattoo anything I say is not
representative any organization or
Google or the lawyers that are
affiliated with me all comments are my
own please do not get a tattoo first off
if you're doing a performance go to
html5 rocks com there's a landing page
it's called performance you click on the
button I'm actually the guy that
maintains that page right if you start
there it's going to walk you through the
three pillars of web performance you're
going to be able to go step by step on
how to find and address the largest
problems on each one of these three
pillars next is you need to be following
and using the perf matters hashtag we
actually started this hashtag just
earlier this year and we really we
wanted to use web perf we really did we
wanted to use that hashtag it was out
there but we didn't feel
get bruised enough egos we wanted perf
matters to be this name this brand this
answer to a question right and what we
saw was very quickly people started
hosting links to their friends websites
and be like yo dude why does it take 15
seconds to load your site perf matters
right we wanted it to be something you
can take to your manager and say hey it
takes 15 seconds for our site to load on
mobile perf matters we want this to be a
badge we are all egotistical programmers
wear the badge right on the sticker make
it a part of your culture make it a part
of your environment that's what we want
we want attitude in that that's why you
should follow that hashtag finally check
out the G+ web performance community if
you're in Google+ it's a cool place a
lot of cool people hang out there some
of them are bold some of them post
content I'm not saying who but you need
to follow that because really if you
combine perf matters with the Google+
web performance communities and the
articles coming through html5 rocks
you're actually going to find an
overflow of information I bet most of
you in here haven't actually dived into
over here will do this will do this put
your hand up if you've read more than 5
articles about performance ok we're
going to keep and keep your hands up
keep her hands up more than 10 articles
ok let's let's ramp this exponentially
20 28 let's go 40 articles on
performance ok ok if you for those of
you who have had your hands up of those
40 articles how many of those things did
you implement maybe 5 6 20 no fair if
you actually did a talk earlier tonight
not taking your input so the point that
we're getting at though is that for
those of you who haven't been reading a
lot of this content is actually going to
be an overflow of information hopefully
you can find it you can guide it you can
move through it what's next one yeah so
what I'm going to do now is with the
rest of the time Pete how much time do
we have 40 60 as much as I want keep
talking until people fell asleep good I
can't do that so we're going to do is a
I'm actually only going to load these
websites on mobile quite frankly I ran
through these two earlier today and most
of your sites actually fell over dead on
mobile there were some interesting use
cases on desktop but quite frankly
desktops dead if you're not making your
site mobile and friendly and fast there
you're doing it wrong period period
period period
Mobile is all that matters right now
hashtag perf matters you can you can
tweet that I'll give you a second now go
ahead it's okay hashtag perf matters
move okay so we're going to take a look
at a couple of these really quick and
I'm going to try to organize these in in
terms of discussion and pointing out a
couple things so if we don't get to all
of them I apologize please feel free to
email me later and curse at me or do it
on social media that's always fun to so
but what I've got here is a little setup
and you can actually see my little phone
so I can click on some stuff and what
I'm using over here is the chrome
developer tools adb extension okay so
this is a fantastic little who's using
this who's anyone using this way no
bitten don't fare if you're hosting the
event dude yeah you guys are cheating so
this is a fantastic chrome extension you
go to the Chrome Web Store you can
actually download and install this
extension basically what allows you to
do is interface with the Android
developer tools very easily and quickly
so I can actually click on this and go
view inspection targets and you'll
actually see that it loads and shows me
this galaxy nexus phone that's actually
plugged in right here right and I can
actually click well I'll close this you
can actually see what this looks like I
can click the inspect button okay and
what this inspect doesn't button shows
is that actually shows me what's on my
phone right now okay so I this is this
is one of the this is one of the sites
i'll get to it in a little bit deeper
here in a minute but this is actually
what's on the on the phone you can see
it's moving it's scrolling it's doing
stuff we go over here and you can
actually see the network so if I hit
reload on my phone you can actually see
the network requests coming through
right there's not the desktop site is
actually a mobile site this is really
good because I'm actually testing on the
device that my users are using wow great
comment hashtag perf matters one of you
will tweet it tonight it will happen
i'll keep drilling it into you so but
the cool thing is you can actually see
what's going on here and and notice for
this particular website that it's
actually not done loading yet right like
you can still see the bar moving on the
side over there and the funny thing is
if you load this site in desktop you
don't see that same problem right so
obviously there's an issue on the mobile
that is not showing up on the desktop
again we need to make sure that we're
testing things properly but the cool
thing is we can actually see all of the
same events use the dev tools in the
same way minus everything crashing
because of memory issues which might
happen tonight I apologize for the live
feed but we can actually go through here
and like
record memory and see what's going on in
memory right and so let me show you over
here like I can go through and actually
scroll and go back and actually see how
memory is adjusting based on this stuff
so if you if you haven't adopted this
chrome ADB extension into your tooling
and your testing you need to definitely
do this definitely get this in your
stuff because I mean no other tool
allows you this sort of integration
right and chrome dev tools are already
top the line it should be part of it so
anyhow enough of me babbling so let's
start with one of the first sites here
come on clicky clicky there's a native
app for you slow and loading right for
Castillo off or I'll get it right sorry
so we're going to try this first one
here ugh this was submitted someone in
the room submitted this I don't know who
it is doesn't matter we're gonna take a
look at your site and hopefully we're
going to make you upset so this is
loading i'm going to show you what the
page looks like first so first off we
all just watched it load this is on a 4G
connection i'm not on the local Wi-Fi
right we can see that this is actually
is not a mobile site right I mean I
shouldn't have to I shouldn't have to
scroll oh I can zoom yay right but kind
of most of the site is actually eclipsed
right we've got some sort of spinner
here at the top it's a marquee movement
we've got some other items down here on
the bottom you know some stuffs going on
so let's take a look at what that looks
like in chrome devtools right so I can
go here click inspect again native
applications they're slow so let's go to
the network tab and I want to take a
look at how this thing loads okay so I'm
going to hit reload again we're going to
watch all the assets come through and
notice here on the bottom here you can
see six requests 12 requests I'll keep
scrolling down the bottom scene kind of
see that 17 7 seconds worth of load time
before it's actually loaded so this down
here on the bottom tells us that it took
about six seconds before content
complete was actually kind of issue
right before the page load event
occurred in 7.9 seconds total 8k
actually came up nope we're still not
done 9k came through pardon me and so 34
requests we can actually see the health
of this object in the health of the site
now 34 request that's actually nothing
9k that's a drop in the bucket you know
the robitussin laced grandmother picture
from earlier could easily load 9k very
quickly
what's important here though and i want
to show you this is when we go up here
and actually sort by size we actually
get a different sort of sense of the
content that's being sent around right
so you can see let me not do that there
we go so we can see the images loaded we
can actually see that most of the large
assets here 6.4 keg 512 bytes we can see
that the large image is here this is
actually interesting me so this is a
1024 by 576 it's 213 k quick round of
applause who thinks that's too large for
a mobile site yeah ok let's here's
another one here's 109k a little bit
better same resolution though anyone
noticed that same resolution half the
size now if you anyone in here as it
quick another round of applause who's
written a JPEG compressor one guy do you
guys three guys alright well we'll get
some beers later and we'll talk about
DCT coefficients I've had this really
cool idea that you can actually you know
they're mine so notice though that this
this image actually has a lot more data
to it right there's a lot more edges
there's a lot more noise to the image
yet it's smaller than this one here
right this is actually mostly pink
there's no reason that the image with
more detail should be less size than the
one with less detail in it right what
this tells me I know nothing about these
developers I don't know think about the
site but this tells me that they're not
actually exporting this particular image
with the right compression settings so
another I like doing these polls because
it's late and I need you all entertained
so how many of you actually just export
your images at some constant format like
when you do an export from a JPEG it's
like on 12 or 80 depending on we're
doing when you're so notin everyone else
hand optimizes exactly your exact
perfect PSN our relationship for your
JPEG yes is that what I'm hearing
because I saw like three hands so either
you're all lying to each other or you
have no idea the way that your images
are round of applause for no idea the
compression quality ok fantastic ok so
seeing this site actually tells us that
this is a systemic problem and again the
3000 developers I've talked to over the
past week I'll see this problem a couple
of the other websites i'm going to load
tonight you're going to see this show up
very prevalently that in general we as a
web community do a horrible horrible job
of optimizing images for koala
sighs now in reality this isn't
something that's that difficult most of
us consider a single way pipe right we
have artists or designers that are
working in a vacuum right they're trying
to optimize for the visual quality of
the image meanwhile there's bald
engineers in a corner somewhere going
why is my side slow right and there's
this constant back and forth between
these two camps about size of images
versus quality of images and load times
and all this stuff let me give you a
little more dove advice if and if you
are able to implement something like
this it's very simple to spin up an
Amazon ec2 instance or even do this at
your desk and actually run a compressor
a command-line compressor like lib jpg
or jpeg turbo by the way jpeg turbo is
the actual codec that we use inside of
chrome for JPEGs and actually compress
it at various quality settings and test
the PSN r of the images PSN are for
those of you who don't know is peak
signal-to-noise ratio this is actually a
measurement of the amount of noise and
error that's introduced to an image the
blockiness that actually comes from the
compression format we actually of a
standardization process we call it PSN
are and that's how we compare image
compressors to each other so you can
actually take your image compress it at
level 90 see what the PSN RS compress it
at ATC where the PSN Rs 70 60 50 40 30
you get below 30 you've gone too far
just stop at 30 right but the cool thing
about this is that you can actually run
10,000 20,000 30,000 images through this
process and for each one find the exact
right compression value to give you a
PSN are of around 38 to 45 right so
you're not actually just exporting to a
single compression number a slider that
your artists have no idea what it does
you can actually programmatically find
this value by implementing a simple
iterative process against the
command-line compressor that's kind of a
cool round of applause for cool I saw
some of you bruh grudgingly go that's
not cool let's save the questions for
the end if that's okay because otherwise
I'm going to stare at Putin and he kind
of scares me so let's take a look at
some other things here so I want to go
over time line so that was load time
everyone knows the network stuff if
you're not using webpagetest org or
paged mod PageSpeed or PageSpeed
insights and all that stuff you need to
be using all that so let's just take a
look at what this site's doing while I'm
doing nothing so now I haven't touched
the site to be clear my phone almost
actually went locked
I haven't touched it I'm still not
touching it but i want you to notice
what the memory is doing on the top now
i'm a c++ game developer write to me the
only thing that matters for performance
is follow the memory Ryan actually gave
a talk at velocity yesterday where I in
a very hairy take fashion suggested that
web developers were really bad
developers because we're not controlling
our memory we're actually letting
JavaScript do it for us and because of
this we have no idea what's going on
under the hood right how many of you
know what your heap sizes how many of
you care that's another question I like
that I like your outfit does that like a
comer like what is that tell your real
work yeah I like that that's cool I'm
after give me one of those perf matters
I got to get me one of those so again
I've touched nothing but but notice this
here on the top I don't know if you guys
can see it it's allocating between 7.5
Meg's and nine Meg's I'm touching
nothing nothing's occurring on the
screen you get two megabytes of data are
being allocated and cleared in this
environment now I can actually figure
out what's going on with this if I stop
my recording too much information let me
just do a quick record real quick so I
can clear all that so we can see
something on the timeline here so it
looks like first off they got like two
different timers firing right so we've
got widgets jsin chart beat chart BTW
i'm guessing is like an analytics thing
i see this on a bunch of sites you guys
gave me and then widget seems like
they're think so i'm guessing this is
that Marky scroll at the top right
they've got some timer that's actually
moving those images around what I don't
like pardon for widget shot jazz oh cool
oh nice which is Dutch ass Twitter oh
cool so Twitter is actually screwing
this page up go Twitter say my name from
Twitter boo Twitter so what we see down
here though is we see recalculate and
paint and whatnot for our memory this
view doesn't actually tell us what's
being allocated I mean we can see where
the events are occurring and whatnot I
can actually mouse over the GCS when
they actually happen more importantly
though I can actually go over here to
the profiles page because I don't like
seeing that kind of memory and I can
actually do a record of heap allocation
right so I can just hit start and let
this thing run and basically what you're
seeing here is on this topic eynde of
seeing Timeline view plus memory
profiling at the same time in the top
any sort of any of these
blue lines is when memory allocations
occur now when you see a gray line with
the gray line means is that memory has
been freed by a garbage collection
process somewhere so you can actually
see a new set that just happened and
some of the gray lines happen but you
know these blues tend to kind of pop up
in a very regular fashion now in this I
can actually go through here and change
the size of my window and actually see
exactly what was allocated so in this
single event at about eight seconds in
in my capture about 3k worth of data was
allocated we can see a similar pattern
over here right I can highlight this
window and we see another about almost
3k right and over here a similar window
is about 3k plus a lot of extra change
there that hasn't been freed up yet but
let me focus on this guy really quick so
here I can actually see that 3k came
from compiled code so somewhere in the
systemd optimization code came from now
for those of you who are not versed in
fast path and slow path JavaScript
effectively what this little block of
data you're seeing here see that the
optimization data the way that v8 and
most modern JavaScript VMs work is they
will actually try to optimize your code
on your behalf because I mean come on
you're a stupid programmer you don't
know how to write code obviously the vm
knows better than you because it's a
machine that it's fast and it's smart so
what it will actually do is take a code
path that you've written it'll actually
optimize it it'll manage the memory
it'll make some fast path optimizations
and it'll put it out there and start
running it well the problem is that it
does this with some assumptions about
the state of the environment that it's
in and it will do this and often time
it'll break and go whoa whoa we actually
cause an exception somewhere in a stack
due to our optimization because we're
just a stupid robot we actually don't
know what we're doing either when this
happens basically Chrome has to create
this new block of code that's parallel
to the block of code you had delete your
block of code put your new block of code
in the stack and have it executes when
that D optimization occurs because the
optimization failed it has to take your
old block of code put it back in and
delete the block of code that it just
created so there are specific code paths
that generally caused this to happen
closures are one of them how many of you
are using closures and your timers don't
applaud I don't I don't want you to
applause that okay closures are one of
these things if you actually have a
closure running and so it's very common
for people to do set interval closure
comma 1000 right that closure
in that set interval is actually causing
these sorts of memory leaks to occur
right it's addie optimization path that
v8 can't optimize around and so
basically every single time you're doing
this you're running into this situation
so let's take a look at something else
really quick so I want to go over here
and show you what I'm seeing on the
screen now I've turned on a couple modes
on the developer tools so first off
you'll see this beautiful little you
can't see it too well what if I can't oh
my phone just a little bit you can see
up at the top that I actually have a
little graph showing me frame rate as
well as how much GPU memory is being
used right so this is actually for quick
show of hands who understands how a web
page is painted it's like the same guys
that wrote jpg compilers ok so for
everyone else let me do this really
quick how your page is rasterized is a
delicate ballet counting really it's
more like boxing it's basically two
people smashing each other's faces in
for about six milliseconds of frame
effectively what happens is chrome will
take your web page and it will dice it
up it'll create square regions of 256 x
256 tiles for each one of these tiles
that actually spin up a thread and
actually rasterize all the pixels in
that tile all of the WebKit i well blink
now sorry I gotta get my terminology
right all of the page elements and
actually composite that to a cpu chunk
of memory 32 bits per pixel 256 x 256
tile and no rasterize all that data in
there once that data is rasterize it'll
then upload it to the GPU when you
scroll a page the GPU is actually the
thing that's moving your page now for
those of you some of you in here young
much younger than me you may not know
this but back before quake 3 was
hardware accelerated we had something
called software rasterization yeah
software rasterization heritage doom
quake anybody any other professional
gamers in the house yeah so back then we
use a term called software rasterization
this was generally ok but once we
invented GPUs GPUs are basically
hardware rasterization they're built to
take pixels and put them on the screen
their dedicated silicon for this right
but chrome is actually still using
software rasterization to paint the
pixels on the screen this means that
this is a slow path this also means that
every one of you right now should be
really really scared because how many
you have actually tested whether or not
those rounded corners and drop shadows
affect your render time they do actually
quite frankly if you go to html5 rocks i
actually did study on this haha i'm
sorry that was a leading question that
was mean i I knew that you didn't know
that answer but basically what happens
is your CSS effects actually caused
right it has to be software rasterize
which means we have to actually go and
draw rounded rectangles and then
actually add a drop shadow to the side
of it right and this is actually takes
more times in fact if you have those two
combinations of things together it
actually takes for X as long as each one
of them individually which means that
there's combinations of CSS properties
that hurt your rendering performance
more than others hopefully all of you
were going dear God I have to test this
right now okay and how you can test this
is you can actually see up here in this
GPU of this frame rate meter is that as
you're scrolling you can actually see
the milliseconds taken to render that
part of your page now what you're also
seeing here is notice this big red box
that keeps popping up this is actually a
mode in chrome devtools let me show you
this and i know i'm spending more time
on this site as we go to the other sites
you actually see this stuff play out but
i need to kind of test the groundwork
here is that in or left left oh wow okay
I'll keep working so anyhow I've show
paint rectangles on basically what this
does is when I turn this on it's going
to show a red rectangle for every part
of the page that actually gets repainted
so this actually tells me what part of
the page is being rear aster eyes which
is really cool to know because I'm
pretty sure all of you will look at your
foot site and find that you've got some
little square icon like this but for
some reason it's rasterizing like a 6x
size window of that that all has to be
reprocessed on the cpu this slows down
your page it creates jank I hate that
word hitching by the way hitching is the
right term every other medium video
games AV movies it's caused called
hitching just can we all agree to use
hitching no I'll get hitch free org
later anyhow so let me let me move on to
the next site so I'll make sure that we
talk about some more stuff but basically
you can see that on this side there's a
couple things first off they're sending
two large images to a mobile device they
don't have a mobile view they don't have
a set of a viewport for these mobile
environments plus it seems like they're
their marquee is actually rendering and
updating different parts of the page
different frequencies they're allocating
about a Meg of men
Murray per minute or so that when no
one's touching anything so if this is
your site fix those things because you
need to and also your load time is
pretty pretty hard too so let's do this
in excellent so this next one should be
pretty quick I just want to highlight
something really really poignant here so
I'm going to close this witch viewer you
want okay so let's show you so this is
dosomething.org cool little website it
kind of just encourages everyone to do
something interesting and like small
little you know small butterfly wings
change the course of tides in Africa and
all that stuff but we we see it's pretty
simple website right just kind of a
little strata of images and whatnot when
we go over here to chrome devtools let's
inspect this information here and I'm
going to put this back on the network
tab and we're going to go ahead and
reload this so we can actually see the
page loaded pretty quickly we got a lot
of information really quick about 2.9
seconds so there's a lot better than the
previous website right we got it we're
right around that three second load time
right and there's again this is on my 4g
i'm not on the wireless so that's pretty
good 10k transferred okay that's all
right 21 requests not that bad at all so
let's again sort by size let's see if
anything's coming up here got a couple
not found that's not necessarily a good
idea a couple images here so this is
interesting again another 106 k image
that's being delivered to a mobile
screen that obviously does not need 106
k that one's a little bit better well
not better I mean that's a very
depressing image I didn't I didn't mean
that that was again my my opinions are
my own and not that of any
organizational or secret service that
I'm influenced with so we can actually
see some of these images may be a little
bit larger than others but for the most
part this is actually nice deported what
happened here did I this technology
isn't it great so we can actually see
though that this this page is actually a
pretty good example of what to do on a
website right if you load this on the
desktop what you'll actually see is that
there's larger versions of these images
they're tiled differently with a
different layout there's a different
scheme but in the mobile version they
really only have one or two images that
are probably too large for the mobile
ice but in the most part this actually
Scrolls pretty quickly right if I know
you can't see it up in the top here but
this is actually about three
milliseconds 25 milliseconds to actually
draw the part of the page and you can
actually see that as I'm scrolling
notice that there's no red tiles right
you don't see those big red flashes what
that means is this entire page has
actually been rasterize on the cpu and
uploaded to the GP and it's been cashed
in the GPU and so as you're scrolling up
and down the CPU doesn't have to do any
work right so this is what you want you
want no red blocks going on your page
all right so let's do let's do another
site here really quick because now I'm
freaking out that I only got 30 minutes
yes we're going all night let's just
open up every website okay so this is
the one we saw a little bit earlier
sorry I don't know if my antics
distracted you all let's let's reload
this again let's let's see how the load
time is so so notice on the top here
that it's about halfway so this page
hasn't unloaded yet let's just be clear
about we're looking at this is an
instant lo this is on now we've actually
got into the loading part if this is
your website I'm sorry hopefully you
understand there's work that needs to do
it might be let's find out so again over
here let's go to inspect I wonder if I
can just catch this midstream if it'll
just tell me what that images or do I
five to hit reload it's still loading
okay here i'll hit reload see what goes
on here 00 web fonts okay we'll take a
look at that in a second okay so I hit
reload this is waiting to reload so
obviously there's already some problems
to the site hopefully someone in here is
going like ah please stop clicking
buttons please take my website off of
your screen you angry bald man okay
let's let's see how this is going here
so so you can't see the screen it's
still loading the the fonts just now
appeared let's take a look at what's
going on here and see whether or not we
can discuss some of these items so let's
sort by size here uh this this is
something I want to let everybody know
because this is this is the first thing
I want to point out on the site this is
a wha file it's a web font round of
applause if you're using web fonts in
your site good please stop
please please stop this is a I don't
know if you saw this yeah webfonts look
great they're awesome this is a 38k for
that web font and unfortunately like I
some of these are have been cached right
so you can actually see the true size of
a lot of these but there's actually like
five or six web fonts on this page so
you guys are kind of getting a bum deal
you're not seeing how horrible this is
but basically here's what happens is
when you've got five web thoughts each
one can be somewhere between the range
of 40k and like 90 k for a font that
font is required before text can
actually be drawn to your screen okay so
pop quiz what happens if you're ready to
draw text but you're in your CSS is down
and your javascript is down and your
images are down but your Wafaa isn't
down yet good answer I don't know no one
said anything good nights or nothing
nothing happens chrome will do nothing
chroma block chrome will wait chrome
will wait for every single one of your
WAAFs to come down before a single
character of text is drawn on your
screen Jake Archibald says I'm dumb if
that single woof is visible to render
that one now firefox will do it a little
bit differently basically what I'll do
is it'll wait three seconds right Jake
yeah it'll wait three seconds maybe you
should you have an awkward like moment
yeah basically what happen with Firefox
is it'll start the request for the woof
if it hasn't been downloaded in three
seconds it'll actually I'll keep
allowing that to display or to download
but it'll actually display the font with
a default like it'll just see Ariel so
if you're actually seeing this on
Firefox you'll see like three seconds of
nothing and then you'll see Ariel and
then when the font comes in you'll see
it pop to whatever the fonts supposed to
be and so you see this flickr i see it
you see it a lot on mobile right because
these mobile devices are actually 6x
slower in hardware just across the board
probably for at least another two years
depending on which hardware manufacturer
you're trending then what you're seeing
on the desktops not only is it slower to
download these things but these walks
are actually very complex spline path
that actually be interpreted by these
under powered arm chips as well anyone
in here written a software rasterizer
cool spline paths or slow anyhow WAAFs
are bad and you should feel bad if
you're using them in your websites right
now now things are being happened
are trying to optimize this right I know
that there's people talking about
different ways to compress WAAFs in
different ways to to use these type of
fonts in different ways but please note
that if you have them as part of your
site you should feel bad now let me see
if I can kind of like shift reload this
I don't know I can't get the data from
cash but we also see in here a couple of
these things that I can't show you this
but these images are actually a little
bit larger than they should be as well
these are okay is that Willie Nelson
again there's another woof this PNG
where was this header on that this one's
a web p Oh fantastic so this guy was
actually using a web p interesting I
don't know what that's doing that was
the accept header yeah so at least a web
p did come down however we see that
let's go down here again 124 case you
again you guys are getting the the bad
rap because I'm not doing a cached fresh
reload on this but basically this site
is using its actually passing like full
megabyte to megabyte images down it's
got the WAAFs in the direct path to
rendering and so that's going to take a
long time before textual show up in fact
the image you'll try to progressively
load in before all the text does and
this will annoy your users a lot more so
let's try to avoid that all right let's
try another website here really quick
let me go this is anyways anyone has any
one sad yet about the state of things is
anyone is anyone going like wow I wonder
how my site does under this type of
scrutiny if so then yeah I'm doing my
job I can get paid this week cool that
was actually pretty quick that actually
wasn't that bad right let me do that
again all right yeah that actually
wasn't that bad and I see if I can hard
load load load good cool okay so this
might this might be a good site let's
take a look this one so we'll hit
inspect again we'll load it up see here
scrolling actually seems pretty smooth
on this site right doesn't seem doesn't
seem that bad we can move stuff around
pretty easily
let's take a look at the network tab
let's hit reload again again
unfortunately on all of this stuff is
coming from the cash now I should use my
other tablet dot-com CSS not that bad
22k CSS 27 k CB SS 200k I don't like
this hundred and ninety-two k.jpg that's
only 920 by 300 notice this so this is
192 k for an image that is a quarter of
the size of Putin quick show of hands
who knows what that means yeah not
optimizing your JPEGs I think there's
actually some other bad examples here
here's another one 240 k 0 0 240 k 9 20
x 300 does anyone off the back of your
hand know what this is if it were a raw
image size so it's 209 20 x 300 x 32
bits per 24 bits per pixel then i get
back to me Jake will give you some swag
oh there's a Facebook icon only 9k yay
that's a wokay that's 100 by 100 is 9k
that seems a little bit excessive right
that's that seems like there's actually
some bloat going on there i wonder if
there's like a negative jpeg encoder
make it larger by the way if any of you
are going to be in san francisco next
week or have a chance or have the
internet i think definitely tune into my
talk I'm giving on compression on the
web and hopefully if you've seen my
talked yesterday about quote being
scared of closures if you see my talk
next week on compression on the web
hopefully compression will scare you
after that and you'll you know dredge
toward that monster with a weary eye but
anyhow hunter k 100k pixel is 3.9 k
inside so that actually seems a little
bit excessive there too here's again
some those are the same images here's
another one these are these are really
large 180 k being sent to my mobile
device now the reason this loaded again
this loaded a little fastest is a bias
because I've been testing these things
all day and this is coming from cash so
you're not really feeling as much pain
as you should be beautiful alright Jake
Archibald for the win here let's hit
reload now
there we go oh yeah Oh feel it feel it
so awkward right now it kind of should
be yeah oh so no one's hiding their face
right now so maybe the guy who put the
site in isn't here or you're you've got
a great poker face I will not I will not
bet money against you okay so and then
they shrank right so oh great that's
actually a great point I'll bring this
up really quick to how many of you have
responsive websites okay you're doing it
wrong um yeah let me let me ask that in
a better way how many of your responsive
websites will actually resize the image
that you've been given jake would you
say you got a CSS resize are you
changing the properties of it if it
comes down is 1024 by pixels by 1024
pixels and you display it as 900 pixels
by 900 pixels or something like that
anybody resizing you tell me every
single one of you gives exactly the
right pixel ratio for every single
device that loads your website is that
what I'm hearing all right that guy's
hiding his face so I know he's doing it
wrong at least you know at least you're
honest brother I guess I'm swag for you
after this so here's something a lot of
you don't know decoding a JPEG or PNG or
web p file actually takes time from your
CPU and in fact you know how is talking
about those tiles getting rasterized
what happens is before a tile can be
rasterized chrome actually has to go
decompress all the images that are in
that tile now when that tile is evict
'add from the cash we're going to have
to repaint it again sometime layer well
lo and behold there's actually a texture
decompression cash as well so there's a
chance very high high high chance on
mobile devices that will actually
decompress a JPEG file right and then
have to resize the uncompressed version
of it right so you're actually getting
full 32-bit pixels actually being
resized from 10 24 25 12 and then the
next time you have to render that image
you have to decompress it and resize it
again right so if an image is split but
Queen two tiles you can run into a very
awkward situation where you have to
decode and resize that image for each
tile that it's split in so if you're
resizing your images dynamically right
now this could be a problem for your
site hopefully some of you I saved the
questions for the end I said it to that
guy I gotta say it to you too it was
that because I called you for Castillo
okay that's right much love well anyhow
I so I think we kind of see that this
white this website has some issues and
most of it is on the network tab let me
go ahead and turn on continuous show
paint rectangles as well because I want
to show this off too so see that red
rectangle so you can kind of see this
little one let me show it on the screen
here you can see this woman little pop
it up but watching this red rectangle
happened full screen do you see that see
that again poop poop poop poop of home I
see this almost on every single site on
this list basically they've got a
marquee on top and that marquee for some
reason is actually invalidating the
entire page below it as well so the
actual div that's expanding this thing
that's getting repainted is touching
every single pixel on the page right
which means that even sitting here doing
nothing we're actually the CPU is just
sitting here spinning and spinning and
spinning and spinning and working and
working and that's actually going to
make scrolling not as smooth as possible
and you can't see it I can feel it a
little bit here this is actually a
pretty janky website up at the top it
says that our average frame rate right
now is about 18 frames a second 17
frames a second right I can actually
really feel this on mobile now I have 30
minutes yes 15 minutes of filler so
obviously this is a problem and because
when I see something dynamic like this I
generally think that memory is going
wonky as well so let's go ahead and do a
timeline and hit record again let's see
what's going on we've seen this before
right same same pattern we saw with the
other site we see just kind of memory
just being allocated and allocated an
allocated an allocated let's hit stop
and see if we can drill in and see what
the culprit is again I know nothing of
these websites I know nothing of you
know I'm just a primitive C++ developer
your web
development scares and confuses me so
let's let's go to profile and let's do a
record heap allocation so we can see
that memory is a problem now it's
digging a little bit deeper let's record
a heap allocation mmm okay again i'm not
touching anything on the website in
memory 10k 5k 10k 5k let's hit stop boom
let's try to drill in here on one of
these guys let's just look at this one
compiled code looks familiar again oh
wow it's almost like we've seen this
exact three the lines of code before
right so again I know nothing in this
website I haven't even looked at the
source code yet but something in here is
already passing a closure to a set
timeout or a set interval sorry sometime
I was a different operating system but
there's a lot of other stuff going on in
here to write like it looks like some
other relocation info is going on I
don't see any injections which is good
so like no one's cause it calling eval
because otherwise we probably see the 6k
worth of information someone laughed
that's probably good eval is bad and you
should feel bad so if you're using
closures and eval just get out just just
get out dude I'm gonna see a web I'm
gonna see a tweet Colt says you set
interval with closure and eval perf
matters yeah yeah with a woof inside of
a woof by the way I saw some of the
other day that actually had a woof
embedded inside of a CSS and I was like
okay that's just a bad idea from all
principals right like so you have the
CSS gets bloated and then the wop has to
be in anyhow we see this other part is
an array now this is this is interesting
so when you see this array object this
means this is an actual JavaScript array
that is allocated somewhere on the page
and you can see some of it is coming
from internal with v8 write the code
Diop data but otherwise the relocation
info here's like a null a null array is
just being created for no reason and no
no items are being added to it we can go
down here to string and we can see a GM
string has been created somewhere let's
kind of scroll us up we have a new
information yeah yeah that's what's
going on right here so this is there's a
regex occurring somewhere GM's being
created then there's some system level
stuff this is mostly dragons and Krakens
and you know other things going on with
the hood if we expand this little bit we
can actually slide over and see again
compiled code right oh there's there's
another relocation photo to see if
there's a diop this time no that makes
sense because the spikes not as high
on this guy compiled code relocation yep
spikes not as high again so again d opt
is actually what's causing the memory
spike here and then of course that's
that's causing inflation in our heap so
we can actually see there's a couple
problems obviously they're sending too
much data down the pipe this page is
loading slowly the person should feel
bad they've also got some timers and
some closures and some memory leak
issues that are causing some friction
with their users let's load another site
dude here we go chesil chrome always
thank you alright so let's see this one
who thinks is gonna be a fast site show
hands no hands good job you win I like
the spinner we're trying to load we're
letting you know that we don't know how
to do this oh sorry that was below the
belt oh I'm sorry I'm sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I thought it was a good idea
we see it in gmail I don't know um like
a we're not ready to figure out how to
how to stream content yet we saw a load
that was good so let's do this again
actually let me show scrolling doesn't
seem that bad let's click on something
that was actually pretty fast I was
actually a little too fast hold on wait
a minute let me go back okay back up
slow let me click on something else like
trust no one right I don't trust anybody
wow that actually loaded a lot faster in
the main site let's drill in here hold
on on it I'm going dude you're messing
it up Jake who's got the microphone I
didn't either up your talk so let's take
a look at this here so I'm going to go
to network tab and I'm going to hit
reload again here boom we're going to
take a look at this let's see what's
going on so it was really weird the main
page loaded slow that was awkward but
then all subsequent clicks loaded
actually really really really fast which
tells us if you can't get the main page
right why are you getting the sub clicks
right that's kind of awkward so we're
still loading we're still loading we're
still loading again I always sort by
size right because I'm I'm a big dude
who says that memory is where the
performance problems are
we can actually see that they're loading
I'll kind of give away the punch punch
line here but these images were on the
subpages not the main page but they're
being loaded on the main page anyone
figure it out yet basically what they're
doing is they're loading all of the
images for all of the articles that you
would click to before the main page is
loaded they're basically trading off
right there saying your initial load
time is going to be really crummy but
every click after that's going to be
golden right so they're kind of giving
up that initial three second load time
to get one second load times later I
don't know how that maybe that's a
discussion again here's a woof anyone
like WAAFs now answer should be no but
yeah this is really interesting that
we're seeing some of these images let me
see if I can sort this again and see if
we can't get bit better here's another
PNG again this is not on the main page
right so let me let me hit back here let
me again let's just show you the main
page here even clicking back take some
time no backe no I guess not okay you
we're stuck now there we go so yeah so
notice this right here like so this was
kind of one of the last things I clicked
on they kind of have a little drop down
so yeah basically each one of these
items the image is and sort of like the
extra content is loaded in the main page
not the subsequent page right we're kind
of seeing that breakdown and a lot of
these charts here all right so here they
have a couple lower res versions here
two three so so remember when that 100
pixel x 100 pixel facebook icon was 9 k
here's a 320 x 180 that's 10 k so again
don't trust your facebook icons i would
like to say don't trust facebook but i'm
not loud to say that on camera sorry
again here perfect here's a 320 x 180
that's exactly 9.1 k so again i think
all of you should be questioning how big
your images are but i think this court
side is actually kind of an interesting
case study because they've definitely
traded off one type of load time for
another type of load time and i'm not
really sure why or where the
vacation or where the justifications of
that are but I think we can definitely
all agree that the 20 years that we've
had on the web have all kind of
accumulated that the initial load time
is pretty much the most important thing
because that's the first thing your user
feels like none of you have seen this
site except for the one guy who
submitted it and all of you felt the
pain of this site loading for me hitting
a button and it doesn't matter how much
the clicks after that are most of us
would have left the site before we get
to that let me go over here to I kind of
want to show this so notice this I move
now but this this you tube image here
right so if I click this button you'll
see the red boxes again kind of show up
here so we can actually see that the the
video is actually being that part of the
page is being rear-ended right so you
can see again showing that the nope
don't care don't care don't know dumb
stop stop let me click done what I'd
really like to show here and this isn't
really showing up on the on the the main
screen I'm sorry but can anyone see this
orange line right here this orange line
so one of the other interesting things
there's there's a talk that I gave at
Google i/o this year on this its web
it's called web page design with the GPU
in mind so what happens is a certain
elements on a page are kind of imagine
your page is a plane right and all of
your images and all of your texts exist
on this plane right some of those things
are actually propagated to its own plane
so that the web page can actually scroll
in the background and this other pain or
this other plane can actually scroll
relative to it right this is relative
scrolling content let me actually show
you this on a big screen here let me
load up html5 rocks and let's know I
typed in the wrong thing go because i
can type
who's on my internet watch my wife I go
down now I'll try that there we go okay
so I'm going to pick this just a random
article with some random guy on it some
random good-looking guy I think he's
pretty good-looking bald is beautiful
out here so let's go ahead and turn on
this is this is chrome devtools on a
desktop site i know i wasn't going to
talk about this but let's do forced
accelerated and show composite later
borders so turning on layer borders here
shows us what we're seeing normally the
first thing you see is that the blue
lines here actually represent the tiling
of the page in this orange line actually
represents something that's been
promoted to its own layer so how many of
you are using translate Z trans lazy
translate 3d this is the the hardware
accelerated fast path that the silver
bullet that makes your web fast because
you're suddenly using the GPU on the web
it's so amazing actually that's not how
it works what happens is when you use
translate Z or translate 3d you're
actually promoting these pieces of
content to its own plane this is
actually a separate set of tiles so
remember how I said the GPU will
actually scroll your tiles on the screen
when you actually use translate Z you
get another layer that the GPU also
controls now I'm going to see if I can
do this because for some reason we get
paused in the debug too much clicking so
as I scroll here notice how these
objects on the side watch this the table
of contents has not orange right and so
once it gets to a certain part it
actually gets promoted to its own layer
the orange border represents different
layers in GPU memory and then as I
scroll down the page they actually stay
static anytime you have relative
scrolling content on your page you're
actually going to want to promote it
with this translates your translate 3d
now beware this actually puts a lot of
pressure on your GPU so for all of you
who are just going to start putting
translate Z on every part of your page
we saw this happen a lot because it was
supposed to be a silver bullet every one
of these tiles every one of these layers
is actually contending for residency
inside of your GPU cash which means the
more of these separate layers that
you've actually promoted the slower your
website is going to be so you get an
inverse effect with it right because
basically your GPU is getting overtaxed
more tiles are being evicted from your
cash because more things are fighting
for residency it's actually going to
slow down your site because your CPU
spinning up more anyhow enough with the
desktop stuff desktops dead no one wants
to desktop okay let's go back over here
this thing because the web the mobile
web is sexy what was I showing off yeah
so of course this qz site it's actually
a little bit interesting because we see
we see mostly that as we're scrolling
notice the big red spots that keep
popping up you see if i get it to do
that again yup see it so something's
going on it turns out i'll say i'll
spare you the punchline here what's
actually occurring is that these guys
are doing something with a scroll
handler in here where they're actually
trying to catch what I'm doing they're
trying to catch my little scroll they're
trying to reposition things and as soon
as soon as they touch the Dom the whole
Dom has to be recalculated soon as the
whole Dom has to be recalculated all the
tiles have to be redrawn right so as
soon as they try to touch catch what I'm
scrolling and reposition things manually
they're actually invalidating the
hardware compositing and the GPU
scrolling that we're trying to do on
their behalf and actually messing up
their entire frame rate how many of your
mobile sites are catching a user input
like this yeah I saw that I saw that at
least you at least you're honest
forecast I oh they know what's going on
guys I got it right I got it right he
didn't know he's still hates me that's
okay all right let's say this isn't do
some other website speed how we doing on
time 15 minutes I can I can load all the
websites in 15 minutes so let's look at
a couple other ones here let's see let's
take a look at it something good so that
everyone walks away from here with
feelings of happy bunny times sorry i
just called somebody so this is a meetup
com boom okay so we didn't see a loading
spinner that was kind of nice but it did
take a little bit long to load in
general though let's see how it Scrolls
that's actually pretty fast notice I let
me turn the show come let's open the dev
tools again and see what kind of red
things are occurring and what
kind of load times we're experiencing
here so turn on the dev tools let's hit
reload and see how the network performs
not that bad not that bad on the device
I'm actually seeing things starting to
pop up already I noticed no WAAFs in the
code that's really good oh there is one
sound of a bitch what did that come from
Oh bogus well maybe they're not using it
on something critical let's sort by
content here this is really cool to see
right we've actually got a 44 k
javascript is actually the biggest part
of the page I'm surprised that's not
jQuery at 191 k how many of using
getting you know it never mind just
never mind okay actually this image is
popping up to the top 60 k jpeg 320 x 2
26 that's it's maybe a little large
another 60 k jpeg another's 50 k jpeg
this is really interesting too because
we just saw 3 40 x 2 26 s on the
previous site there were about 10 K
right so again someone's not optimizing
JPEGs the right way in fact there's
actually on the article that I put on
html5 rocks about image compression let
me see if I can tap over there really
quick
so the this article that i did was
actually image compression for web
developers is the entire point of this
article was to talk to all of you in a
very frank way and kind of discussed the
backstory of where image compression
works plus i'm a real big fan of parrots
they're kind of cool especially the
digitally pixelated ones anyhow there's
a there's some great content down here
about jpeg information and it actually
shows that here it is right here let me
see if i can zoom this in oh no too far
ok so this is actually I feel it's
important to kind of break away from our
regular scheduled bashing of these
websites because that's getting a little
depressing right everyone's getting
depressed so this is actually a test
that an external person did on the
websites on the the compression quality
of images that are being served by the
top websites of the world and what
you're actually seeing here is most of
them actually just use a standard value
right so all window live background
images are exactly 82 regardless of what
the PSN are is they choose 82 it's hard
coded right so they might be able on
some of the images to use a level 64 and
actually reduce the size more this they
use a to Wikipedia are all 80 for every
one of their images regardless of the
content quality on it YouTube is about
70 to 80 to that's kind of good it shows
that they're actually doing some dynamic
scaling although it's unclear whether or
not that it's actually manually scale do
they have an artist actually changing
them or they have some sort of dynamic
solution like I was saying Yahoo 69 291
a good again they may have some more
responsive version of that Facebook's or
at 85 and google image thumbnails are
about 74 here's the really interesting
twitter user JPEGs or anywhere between
30 and 100 which means that for some
images they're actually like doing
nothing right and some images they're
doing everything this actually tells me
I don't know if anyone no one's in here
from Twitter right this actually tells
me they may have something dynamic
actually testing the noise ratio of the
compression there and actually serving
you the most optimized jpeg at the best
image quality possible so that's really
cool that's really cool to see that
someone's doing that out on the web ok
back to doom and gloom ok we were over
here so yeah so these images probably
are a little too large in
megabytes you know they're probably not
optimizing it chances are no that's not
an image chances are they're just using
a standard one so let's hit timeline
let's just hit record let's see what's
going on with memory not touching
anything memories increasing not too
much 5.5 5.6 again we've got these
timers getting fired right fine jjs I
don't even know what this is meetup
script mobile find okay so apparently
it's trying to meet me and find me
that's kind of creepy mobile base so
that's weird so they've got two separate
timers coming from their own website
doing two different things and again
right like not touching anything nothing
nothing's happening nothing's moving but
we're we're 5.6 Meg's so it looks like a
slow leak right it looks like there's
there's a slow closure or something
being tossed to this so let's take a
look at this see if we can't drill in
maybe we get some it's oh yay it is a
jQuery library can me some of the power
of pretty print aha that didn't help I
try again there we go Oh mustache
interesting who uses mustache can anyone
explain this line of code to me okay so
this is causing a memory leak can anyone
fix this not now okay that's cool take
your time that's right we'll get back to
it but basically we're seeing again this
looks like a this kind of looks like an
anonymous function calling some factory
objects testing some object definitions
this in and of itself doesn't look bad
although it is calling like another
anonymous function down here sometimes
the pretty print spacing doesn't get it
all right this might actually be sort of
a closure and a closure it looks like
we've got one close there one open here
something's going on any of you who are
using third-party libraries it's
actually really easy to fall in these
traps where they're allocating memory
and doing stuff on your behalf that may
be negatively impacting your performance
and we sometimes ignore these faults and
don't track these faults down because
the fact we get like event propagation
or something else like oh I get a call
back when something occurs you know that
that code you can actually write in
about a hundred lines of your own making
and actually keep it memory performance
but instead we kind of pull in these
large libraries so it's important that
you know these trade-offs when something
like this is occurring let's do another
website Pete we got what 10 minutes left
yeah 10 minutes let's see what haven't
we done here um so I have to load this
because I really don't get this website
oh I really want to talk about the
website more in the performance
characteristics so this is called game
of phones is this your site ok cool I
really don't get this website but but
it's here so we can take a look at it
from a performance perspective basically
what happens is someone will record and
from what I can tell they're like very
politically charged angry arguments and
like you sign up and someone will call
you and play this recorded message
that's like you know blah blah blah
rally fight the power and then like
you have to call someone else on the
list and like try to regurgitate what
you heard and so it's kind of like the
game of telephone right you play as kids
and you're trying to like get all the
way through I have no idea why people
are even doing this like I hate getting
calls from my wife much less random
strangers on the Internet I'm on the
internet because I don't want you to
call me right like that's send me a text
or something like I don't anyhow
personal thing I'm sure it works for
your brother I don't get the end I'm too
old that's my problem
oh you gave a phones awesome oh you know
what you need to do you actually need to
get the voices from Game of Thrones to
actually do the call and then it would
just go through the roof dude HBO might
sue me now sorry about them anyhow let's
look at this from a performance
perspective there's really nothing on
this page I mean it's kind of text but
we're going to run through it anyway
just you guys can kind of see like a you
know the differences in these things so
I might hear okay by the way did you see
actually what we showed up that was this
on the screen sorry this is game of
phones again it's just it's just text
and people calling each other okay this
is it 12 requests what the interesting
thing here is 109 hundred 7k that's a
little odd rightly we're seeing some
other pages come in below that mainly
this is coming from you know a Content
so I mean bootstrap is being included
I'm not really sure I'm not really sure
why this needs bootstrap I guess the
cool kids are doing it yeah and here's
the funny thing we got like bootstrap
min and then like CSS to replace his
bootstrap so that's that's a thing and
then jquery I'm not okay and there's
another bootstrap again and then
telephone graham and then another jquery
are you using to jquery's
okay you're using 'too jquery's do you
know you're using 2g queries now you do
okay and then I like the gif right
sprite cheated I guess here's the cool
thing so a 3 300 x 120 animated gif is
only 4.4 k yet we were seeing like full
JPEGs that were like 9k that were static
right so i'm not really sure what else
to do with this let me hit timeline see
what this is doing here it's got a
little awkward so you're jquery's are
using memory so this is kind of telltale
right like do you have a timer on your
view it looks like you have a timer on
your maybe the audio player yeah it
looks like yeah it does so it looks like
there's a timer here I don't know if you
guys can see this it looks like there's
a timer here and you can see this red
square up here just the play button just
like that play button has a timer that
needs jquery and bootstrap to jquery's
in bootstrap and is allocating like a
meg of memory over like seven seconds so
that's a thing lots of rasterize is
occurring in here lots of recalculates
so not only is it repainting it's
actually retrain it's like updating the
Dom to repaint let's look at this again
that's updating the Dom don't know why
maybe there's a cool jitter effect there
like maybe you know maybe I got this
wrong maybe this is like a I'm actually
looking at the matrix am I looking at
the matrix that would be kind of cool if
I'm like analyte in this sorry I'm
having fun it's it's late and I have to
keep you all awake for like another five
minutes so anyhow I don't like this
trend like you're actually allocating
more memory faster than the other
websites we looked at probably cuz you
have two jquery's but and help let's dig
in so let's go to profiles again follow
the memory find the performance problems
right so we followed the asset memory to
figure out where load problems are we
follow dynamic memory to figure out
where compute problems and render
problems are can I click this button
please clicky you've allocated too much
memory for your site and I can't click
oh there we go okay so let's do record
heat allocations hit start
so that's that kind of interesting you
guys see this pattern so this is
actually really very very regular
allocations that are occurring two
different sets of it but they're almost
deleted immediately except for the stuff
that happened at the beginning of the
trace so see we're seeing the gray lines
right so the gray lines mean that what I
always allocate has actually been freed
now this is this is kind of odd i kinda
want to see where this is coming from
you know i like to dig in and figure out
why i'm so bold so we have the whole
thing yada yada yada let's actually just
highlight this guy here so array what's
transition array so that something's
going on inside of v8 all these are
being deleted compiled code this is adi
ops no relocation info so it looks like
there's just some sort of cases where
jquery's executing again i see this a
lot with closures closures for some
reason tend to bring up this pattern
like jquery is kicking off a closure
that's causing a reflow of your entire
page for a like a five pixel x 5 pixel
icon so you're still loaded faster than
the other side's Bravo round of applause
for that taken yeah there you go ok you
know I'm a fan of the text web that's it
that requires drinking to get more
information out of that anyhow ok let's
load up another one Pete how we doing on
time five more minutes okay let's let's
clear up quickly because I'm actually
really interested to try this robitussin
and whiskey thing I think we have may
have something on there ok let's try
here we go see let's try the CBN week
and we're done I think at this time I
don't actually need to tell you guys
what I'm about to do right this is no I
don't want to translate I used to be
able to speak Chinese it was a beautiful
language so you kind of know what I'm
about to do right like I'm going to load
up networking I'm going to see what
images are too large what javascript is
too large what you're using that you
shouldn't be using we're going to try to
call assets and get rid of extra
networked loads I thought the points
about sprite sheets was perfect earlier
by the way they're not caught they
should be called spray cheese they
should be called atlases you should
actually see my Udacity course rant on
this everywhere else in the in the world
and video games and phone film and
everything we call them atlases you know
what never mind anyhow let's see some
scrolling not that bad let's head over
to dev tools let's take a look at this
under the microscope right let's go back
to network my phone my computer said I'm
done all right this will be the last
site and then we'll actually get to all
the questions and I think we're gonna do
a group question right fantastic so
that's interesting so there's already 89
request 92 requests 93-95 1.5 Meg's
transferred so far 1.9 to Meg's 2.1 95
let's see if we go to sir so here's it
something something interesting up here
so notice this notice is grey bar right
here so in chrome devtools when you look
at this network tab basically you see
two values you see sort of the
semi-transparent and this opaque portion
of these items that semi-transparent
value is actually how long the browser
spent waiting to receive the asset this
is one of the reasons that sprite sheets
are actually so important for you
because the browser is each browser has
a set number of limits of open
connections that will allow to a single
server for Chrome i believe it's around
six right which means if you have like
six six requests in flight it'll block
the rest of the request until a slot
opens up think of it like a caching 54
whatnot and so chrome actually shows you
this here on the timeline
you can see like some of these actually
waited a very very long time in this
case it was actually spent what is this
471 milliseconds waiting what you know
if wants you to request this asset but
it couldn't because there were other
things around the pipe you can kind of
see that this is a function of the fact
that there's about a hundred requests
and 3.6 Meg's transferred for those of
you who don't know the average website
sighs right now according to HTTP
archive is about 1.1 Meg's and that's
for desktop they haven't really got into
a lot of the mobile testing just yet but
obviously mobile shouldn't be 1.1 Meg
right so obviously there's too big a big
a constant here so let's see if there is
any big offenders let's see if images
are a problem who thinks images are a
problem there's a two here's a 300k
image 200k 197 k 161k 152 k what is in
that image where I i think i think it's
bigger than raw yeah yeah obviously
these images are too big they're not
being optimized this should be fixed
right let's take a look at timeline
let's see if anything is going on with
memory hear anything crazy slow again
timer we see this same pattern so we see
almost all of these pattern pages are
falling into the same pattern also
almost all of these pages and some of
them in rare cases are all using jQuery
or jQuery twice you know closures are
being passed off to timers for things
like ads or analytics or marquis and
these themes to be like a common pattern
but you know this is obviously is
causing a lot of memory and a lot of
churn and and some other weird things
going on I can look at the frames times
here and so let me actually do this I
don't know if I showed you guys this
tool no cancel so as I'm scrolling here
and it's not that picking that up okay
nevermind I won't show you that tool
anyhow let's let's be done with this for
the evening because i think pete has
some other stuff he wants to talk to you
guys about tonight so uh thank you for
your time tonight perf matters wait wait
wait no wait no I I'll let you start the
clap in a second so here's how you get a
hold of me if you guys if anything today
was controversial or something worth
tweeting or something
ask more questions about go ahead and
find me make sure you join the Google+
web performance community there's a lot
of great stuff there please for the love
of God use perf matters follow the perf
matters it's a brand you should wear
this at work ok everything you do you
should be challenging your employees
your managers you're the owners of your
company perf matters perf matters perf
matters it's going to be the thing that
separates the billion-dollar companies
from everybody else on the mobile web
within the next year in fact it already
is it's already something nice challenge
everyone hold them to the standards of
perfidy can start the clock yes thank
you